[Música]
hoje veio então a conversar sobre o
projeto rondon
eu gosto muito de tecnologia da
informação quando eu me formei em
medicina e comecei a dar aula na
faculdade comecei a fazer umas economias
pra adquirir um carro mas quando chegou
na hora de comprar o carro eu acabei
investindo no meu primeiro computador é
eu tenho que fazer um esforço pra me
lembrar hoje que quando eu era estudante
não existiam telefones celulares e não
existiam redes sociais
eu estava no projeto rondon a na
amazônia e conheci uma moça a paulista
que tinha um doutorado em física na usp
e como esposo militar veio transferido
para a amazônia ela veio junto com ele e
e estava muito feliz lá
aí eu fiquei curiosa e perguntei como é
que ela tinha conseguido se adaptar
naquela cidade tão pequena vindo de são
paulo com tantas diferenças e ela me
olhou com muita calma e me disse olha na
verdade aqui nós não temos problemas com
internet aqui nessas cidades longínquas
do brasil a gente tem energia elétrica
do meio dia às sete da noite
então o nosso problema é que de noite a
nossa luz é campeões ea gente precisa de
gelo pra comida não estragar o problema
de internet aqui ainda nem chegou
estou contando isso para vocês
entenderem o nível de vulnerabilidade
das cidades aonde os rondonistas vão
estas cidades existem no nosso país e lá
a gente encontrar muitas pessoas que não
sabem o que é
google
eu quero gente começo e dizer pra vocês
que estão aqui comigo hoje alguns dos
rondonistas da a universidade federal de
ciências da saúde de porto alegre
lá de amarelinhos que vieram prestigiar
este tex obrigada pessoal
na primeira vez em que eu cheguei a
participar de uma operação do projeto
rondon me perguntaram pra definir rondon
em uma palavra eu pensei em dizer que
rondon não se define rondon se vive mas
aí me lembrei que na minha vida
profissional eu vinha usando três
palavras conhecimento com paixão e
comunicação como os pilares para a gente
atender e cuidar da melhor maneira
possível dos nossos pacientes a partir
de entrevistas a partir de ouvir esses
pacientes com isso fazer um diagnóstico
e conseguir tratar bem deles e não é
isso o que eu tinha feito ao longo de
toda a minha vida profissional
e aí me dei conta que eu podia levar
essas palavras que eu chamo de palavras
mágicas chamava com os os meus alunos
também para o ambiente do rondon ea
partir daquele momento essas três
palavras passaram a me acompanhar pelo
tocantins pela amazônia a pelo sertão
que foi aonde eu vivi algumas histórias
que hoje eu gostaria de compartilhar com
vocês
tendo como base essas três palavras
chaves
quanto ao conhecimento a gente encontra
que nesses locais as crianças precisam
caminhar muitos quilômetros todos os
dias até chegarem no local onde elas
encontram um ônibus para levá las na
escola isso aquelas que têm o privilégio
de ir na escola e chegando nesse ônibus
pessoal elas usufruem do transporte
escolar
que pode ser deste jeito
além disso no rondon marcou também a
superação de um jovem adolescente que
todos os dias também tinha que viajar
durante muitas horas para chegar na apae
e ele chegava com um sorriso e esse não
é possível desenhar com as mãos
a gente tem pés
essas histórias de superação algumas
vezes chegam a realização dos sonhos
dessas pessoas e nós estávamos em minas
gerais quando coincide com o período da
passagem do projeto rondon por lá
a formatura de uma turma de alunos do
eja é ensino para jovens adultos então
pessoas que não foram na escola na época
em que deveriam e que agora trabalham
durante todo o dia para sustentar a
família à noite vão estudar e eu nós
fomos eu fui com uma outra rondonistas
pra assistir essa formatura
estou fazendo assim porque eu comer
pessoal lá de trás fica lembrando também
chegando lá nos pediram que a gente
dissesse algumas palavras na formatura
que tinha um formato igual a formatura
igual a grade do eixo da pan american
school com os formandos todos com toga
muito orgulhosos a família e nessas
cidades pequenas eles ainda tinha a
vantagem de que estava também presente o
prefeito todos os secretários enfim
todas as autoridades de lá sobre o que
eu falei e conhecimento com paixão e
comunicação e disse que isso era uma
aula que eu dava os meus alunos da
universidade que então eu ia falar pra
ele rápido pra eles rapidinho e quando
eu disse isso
eles ficaram de uma forma tal
emocionados que me surpreendeu muito
porque pra eles têm uma professora
universitária do estado lado do rio
grande do sul e que ia falar para eles
a aula que
ela dava para os universitários
pra mim eu não fiz absolutamente nada
mas aquela gratidão deles na verdade
bateu em mim como um reflexo porque eu
tinha que me perguntar por que eu tive o
privilégio de me informar disse
professora universitária e essas pessoas
estavam agora recém conseguindo concluir
o ensino médio porque antes elas não
tiveram essa chance
então a primeira lição que eu aprendi no
rondon foi o quanto nós somos
privilegiados quanto a gente tem que
agradecer a gente vê muitas belezas da
natureza na enquanto estamos no rondon
mas essa natureza também é muito
importante e ela por exemplo determina
se numa aldeia indígena as pessoas vão
conseguir pegar o barco irem até uma
cidade em busca de atendimento médico ou
não porque durante o período do ano o
rio ceca extinguiu ceca quem está na
aldeia não sai e quem saiu da aldeia não
volta
além disso nós vamos em regiões que
oferece algum grau de a perigos de
riscos
nós estamos em regiões muito lindas que
podem esconder é principalmente nas
fronteiras como a gente teve agora na
fronteira com a bolívia
problemas sérios com um tráfico de
drogas de armas então vocês vão observar
que nesses barcos nós estamos
acompanhados pelos militares e armados
este é o alojamento onde a gente dorme
durante o projeto rondon
eu tenho um colega muito querido que ele
me disse bárbara rubio
eu acho legal rondon mas eu gosto de
dormir com um lençol bem cheirosinho eu
também gosto de dormir com lençol bem
cheirosinho acho que ele tem todo
direito não tem problema nenhum
mas quem vai para fazer o projeto rondon
tem que se adaptar a essas imponência da
natureza e tem que usufruir daquilo que
nos oferece e na verdade esses dois
pontos não são os que mais me impacto
não são os que mais me deixam perturbada
durante o rondon
o que mais me deixa perturbada é a
violência doméstica que a gente vê
principalmente contra a mulher
o que mais nos comove é ver meninas de
10 ou 12 anos grávidas em uma das
missões no nordeste nós fomos para um
local onde tinha acabado de ser
construído um grande parque eólico para
a construção deste parque eólico vieram
para a pequena localidade
muitos engenheiros técnicos de cidades
maiores
quando eles foram embora muitas mulheres
ficaram grávidas as crianças nasceram e
na face
dava pra ver que elas eram filhas de
outras pessoas que não eram daquela
etnia mas essas crianças provavelmente
nunca vão ver esses pais ea a população
se referia a essas crianças com uma
resignação surpreendente incompreensível
pra mim como os filhos do vento
assim como os filhos do vento têm os
filhos do boto cor de rosa e outras
histórias que vocês devem conhecer eu
não sei se me choca mais as
circunstâncias em que essas mulheres
engravidaram ou resignação da população
com essa situação
quando estamos participando então deste
projeto a gente descobre que não são só
as cidades que são vulneráveis
nós também somos agentes e impacta a
cada dia e como não tem internet a gente
não consegue ligar para a família para
os amigos e pedir ajuda
então nasce entre nós um vínculo muito
forte a gente faz uma coisa que é assim
todas as equipes têm um anjo mas o que
ministério da defesa que fica conosco
que é também pra um pouco para a
segurança mas também nosso anjo e cada
um de nós cuida de um outro colega então
nós somos o anjo dele e alguém da equipe
vai cuidar cuidar de nós isso é uma
aprendizagem que eu tive lá e uma
aprendizagem de que quando a gente sabe
que tem alguém que vai olhar pela gente
que vai nos cuidar
a gente enfrenta tudo a gente fica mais
forte porque cada dia vai ter um que
desaba
ou é porque estava muito calor se
desidratou é porque viu alguma cena
muito impactante passou mal mas aí vai
ter 11 anos na guarda que vai ajudar ea
gente vai se revezando
não posso apertar que eu acho que vai
desandar tudo mas aquino no braço desse
rondonista tem uma pintura feita pelos
indígenas com jenny pa
essa pintura a a acaba desaparecendo com
o tempo
agora esse momento em que nós já
estávamos dentro do barco e tem alguns
representantes nessa ordem indígena que
vieram se despedir dos rondonistas
depois a gente ter ficado lá alguns dias
essa essa imagem quem estava lá vai
lembrar para o resto da vida vai ficar
indo e leve
com isto além do conhecimento vocês já
devem ter visto que a gente treina muito
com paixão no projeto rondon se com
paixão é como um músculo que pode ser
treinado o projeto rondon é uma grande
academia onde a gente fica lá fazendo
esse treinamento e finalmente a
comunicação
nesta foto os quatro desta nesta foto
contando no plano mais na frente
contando com o papagaio não entendem
muito a língua um do outro mas dá pra
perceber que de certa forma a gente está
se comunicando então a gente tem a
comunicação do olhar né a comunicação do
sorriso e não importa se é essa senhora
indígena fala a língua dela e eu falo
português nesta aldeia também tem
pessoas que aprendem o português e essas
foram indígenas que num português claro
escreveram para nós foi agora na
operação do rondon de julho de 2017
gostaria que as pessoas que não são da
comunidade indígena nos vissem como
pessoas normais como ser humano não como
bichos mas também acontecem algumas
coisas engraçadas a gente também dá
muita risada no projeto rondon a gente
foi pra uma estava na comunidade no
nordeste brasileiro e organizamos um
mutirão da saúde
e lá no dia não apareceu ninguém
a gente não sabia por que é que multirão
pra eles era mutirão para limpar o lixo
da beira da praia
então a gente teve que resolver esse
problema de comunicação terminando eu
queria mostrar pra vocês
esse hospital dos povos indígenas onde
toda a família acompanha o paciente
quando ele vai se internar mostrando o
valor da família para essas comunidades
o favor valor do atendimento humanizado
e é a esse reencontro quando a gente
volta com a família transformados que
nos faz ir outra vez quando aparecer um
novo desafio que nos faz praticar essas
três palavras e que nos faz é levar
adiante o abraço do rondonista que aqui
na frente estava já quase dando a e que
nos deixa mais fortes como seres humanos
e com mais esperança de que o planeta
possa ficar melhor
muita briga
[Aplausos]